we have new information this morning on
the story of a six year old girl who was
involuntarily committed to a mental
health facility in Florida in a body cam
video sheriff's deputies are seen
responding to a call from the girls
school the sheriff's report says she was
destroying property and attacking staff
but in the video
a deputy openly questions why she's
being taken away under a Florida law
meant for people considered a danger to
themselves or others Manuel Bojorquez is
following us no you're not long jail
this police body camera video shows a
Duval County sheriff's deputy leading a
seemingly calm six year-old Nadia out of
school on February 4th in the car the
conversation continued the deputies
heard talking to another officer about
Nadia's behavior while in her custody
she's been actually very pleased right
very pleasant
at one point it appears little Nadia did
not understand where she was going the
girl who has ADHD and a mood disorder
was held in a mental health facility
away from her mother for 48 hours the
girl's mother Martina Falk sitting with
her attorney broke down while watching
the video they argue Nadia should have
never been placed under Florida's Baker
Act which allows authorities to force a
psychiatric evaluation on anyone deemed
a threat to themselves or others
including children if you can't
officials with Duval County Public
Schools say student privacy laws prevent
them from discussing details of the case
they told us Wednesday an initial review
showed the school's handling was
compliant both with law and the best
interest of this student and all other
students at the school the family now
plans to file a lawsuit for CBS this
morning
and while Bojorquez Jacksonville well
how about that the the mother doesn't
know what they're doing the officers
don't know why they're taking the girl
and the officers hats off to them
couldn't handle that's it oh yeah it's
so much great yeah really well done yeah
big questions though about what was
happening with the school system yeah
they didn't know why they were doing
what they were doing but they they
didn't see a problem